let's think about two different
scenarios where i might borrow money
from you so this is me over here and
this is you in the first scenario i
borrow money from you for a relatively
short amount of time so i'm gonna borrow
i am going to borrow 100 from you
100
and then
in one week
in one week i will pay that 100 back to
you
i will pay back the 100 and then i will
pay some interest
some interest and we'll calculate the
interest on an annual basis but
obviously it'll be less than a year's
interest because i'm paying for a week
but we could annualize it it would give
us some annual interest the other
scenario is i borrow for a longer period
of time so i'll do the other scenario in
pink right over here so let's say i
borrow 100
instead of paying you back in a week we
agree that i can pay you back in two
years
in two years i'm going to pay you back
100
100
plus
plus some
interest and what i want to think about
here is there any reason why on an
annual basis i should have a different
interest rate for the short-term
borrowing than the long-term borrowing
you might say look it's the same guy
that's borrowing has the same credit
rating has the same kind of legitimacy
and all of that but you would say well
look
over here in one week there's less of a
chance of something catastrophic
happening there's there's there's more
predictability here i i you have a
better sense of what the world one week
from now is going to look like then you
do two years maybe two years from now we
enter into a hyper inflationary
environment maybe i get hit by a truck
maybe i lose a job there's a lot more
that can happen in two years that could
happen in one week and so you say look i
think that this loan right here is
riskier and it's not always the case
that this would happen
but many times you'd say look if i'm
lending it for longer it's riskier
there's more uncertainty so on an annual
basis on an annual basis i would charge
higher interest
higher interest
on an annual basis annual
annual basis so maybe in this scenario
up here you say look a week i'll charge
you five percent per year interest so
obviously the interest i would pay after
a week would be some fraction of this
some small fraction of five dollars a
five percent and over here since there's
more risk more uncertainty over two
years i will charge you or you will
charge me i should say ten percent
ten percent per year and it's not always
the case that the the longer maturity
debt is going to have higher interest
although it tends to be the case if it
goes lower we'll talk about in a future
video it actually shows that something
bad might be happening the economy or we
might somehow be entering into a
deflationary period but the whole point
in this video is to show you that
depending on how long someone borrows
money from someone else they might want
to charge a different amount of interest
per year depending on maybe on on
perceived risk
the same thing is true when people lend
to corporations or to the federal
government
we're going to see in the next video is
how that plays out in the yield curve